she's vegetarian she asked is there any
meat in this German food it's all meat
that's what German they just eat meat
and drink beer crunch it's pública other
countries always have better chip
flavors in us
smells like glazed barbecue smells like
dirt that's awesome but I don't know
what it tastes like a barbecue is the
right comparison I like that siliceous
favorite but they don't like assault
your mouth but it doesn't have this
flavor is barbecue it's kind of weak
these are great a plus Vita meit's it's
non-alcoholic and get it off my table I
mean as a general rule I stay away from
non-alcoholic things the malted vitamin
soda that can't be good it smells like
prune juice and beer had a baby it was
like toast
it tastes like creamier caramel soda
sort of medicine grape juice it kind of
tastes like beer that you've opened left
and then came back for and left it in
the Sun by accident you know what would
go great in this alcohol that lists this
looks incredible I will say though that
it does look like something very human
that is a really long piece one sausage
good I love it this is bursting with
flavor and some good sausage yeah this
is like what you actually should eat
with beer
I don't like hotdogs that's German
engineering at its finest if you ask me
anyone who dislikes any of this is
tasteless kabak is it that may tiny tiny
particle its looks like frosting like
thick and then it tastes like the inside
of a Ritz bits crackers paint like cream
cheese and yogurt punch you in a kidney
sourness this is not how I'd want to
start my morning good darling let me
give you some salt you do you do Haribo
pietatis japanese oh I like that as
little coins
oh god it's salty what the yeah I spaced
out thanks Bob what was that hey you
know what's gonna improve the licorice
the world's worst candy I should turn a
salt 45 milligrams rhodium I think it's
Vegemite flavored
this is something you give your friend
to let them know you don't want to be
friends mister even had me like going up
there I was getting real excited really
running hot they're like a salty
licorice just straight-up coated he
apologized your name I feel a little
more German - like Carney right
[Music]
I feel like I've been looking my whole
entire life for meat this good and I
never found it